good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday hope
everyone's having an amazing beginning
to there
Friday Friday gotta get down on Friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend I know I am I'm just I'm
so [ __ ] ready [ __ ] I'm so [ __ ]
ready [ __ ] I'm so ready I'm so happy
that it's Friday I'm happy for you I'm
happy for me I'm happy for everyone
listening it's gonna be a great day
I'm really happy for our Australian
testers because it's Saturday is it or
is it like late Friday
the only time when it's not good to be
an Australian toaster is Sunday
yeah but what's worse like a Sunday
night or Monday morning
Monday morning I don't know Sunday I'd
just like to rip the Band-Aid off I
don't like the anticipation
no I get that but like at least Sunday
night like I'm not doing anything I'm
stressed but I'm not doing anything yeah
also like my Sunday nights have
definitely been more
relaxed recently
oh Sunday night is that why probably
because I can hear that song coming down
from the living room where Zach is
watching Sunday Night Football oh and I
feel at ease plus the house of the
Dragon is on honestly Sunday nights are
like fine recently
um so obviously we have a lot of
different stories today I'm assuming one
of them is Pepsi halftime show
um so TMZ just dropped an article that
the Super Bowl lvii is hinting at Taylor
Swift performing at halftime they
dropped a major hint which was I'll just
send it to you so we can include it we
can't talk about it
it's in our chat great
that I mean I would simply pass away
like I mean we all know she's like the
most obvious person who hasn't done it
yet and it's because of her contract
with Diet Coke from 100 years ago it's a
Pepsi halftime show she had like a
non-exclusive non-compete for many years
I do think it recently expired because
it's been like a really long time since
homegirl was doing those Diet Coke
commercials
um but now Apple being the sponsor
no no issues it's anyone's game
literally literally
um just kind of continuing the Sports
Talk that's kind of been the thread
throughout this week I think it's
important that we um discuss something I
found out but that the San Diego charges
that are not charging on the iPad
um they're actually the Los Angeles
Chargers now which makes nobody [ __ ]
sense it's not gonna work for me that's
a problem because Los Angeles just got a
team the Rams and they're firing in all
cylinders winning Super Bowls like you
don't need another team when you just
got one and it's working really well
yeah and I don't have the same affinity
for the last Los Angeles Chargers
because the Los Angeles Chargers didn't
send sign Manti Teo the San Diego
Chargers that are not charging on the
iPad did yeah and I just feel like I've
never been to San Diego but I feel like
I would really like it I've heard him
you would and you would I want to root
for them and I'm already like a
semi-rams fan because they won and
that's
San Diego is where Kris Jenner's from
right
maybe I'm pretty sure I just I think
things were good as they were and this
is unnecessary I personally will still
call them the San Diego Chargers because
they're not charging on my iPad because
I got used to your iPad instead of mine
I really I hope you're happy because I
told my mom yeah but I'm happy if other
people want to call them the LA Chargers
I won't correct you
no no that would be rude
um so today is Friday which means
yesterday the new episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians Season Two Season
Premiere dropped we both watched it
we're gonna do a little TV recap and I
also finally I watched in full the five
episodes of tell me lies I'm actually
really glad I didn't read the book
because now I'm just like enjoying a new
TV show without analyzing every [ __ ]
second of it 100 and apparently it's so
different from the book that if you had
read the book and you liked it you
wouldn't like the TV show but it is an
objectively good TV show I just feel
like I've read books like tell me lies
and I just did not picture Stephen
to be like that like in the in the first
episode when they're like don't get back
into it with Stephen oh Steven Steven so
you're like flashbacks like these sexy
scenes of Stephen and then he shows up
at the engaging party like looking gross
and I'm like this is Steven you're so
and then focused on looks it didn't I'm
so shallow it didn't even occur to me
when I saw Steven that I was like
looking for a hunky man and he wasn't
hunky enough the only commentary I have
on Steven's looks is they obviously had
to do something to make him different
looking from eight years ago versus now
and so the hair changed his hair I think
the hair makes him look younger and that
the buzz 10 makes him look older and
that young Steven should have that hair
and older Stephen should be
buzzed okay so maybe Jackie is unique or
I'm unique but was I the only one who
was just like genuinely shocked that
like that's what Steven looked like like
not that I'm like I mean I am so shallow
and he's super handsome but he kind of
looks like Buster from Arrested
Development but like who cares
I don't know I just thought and first of
all this girl
oh my God I never saw a girl so stunning
in my whole life like first of all she's
giving Lily everyone in the show okay
wait everyone in the show looks like
someone ready
main girl
Lily James
main guy depending on the light Buster
Bluth from Arrested Development or Liam
Payne he also looks like Liam Payne from
One Direction
Diana Meghan Markle oh my God they
literally have the same [ __ ] voice
yes
and wait there was one more oh uh Pippa
is Jamila Jamil yeah they look exactly
like and they both have the bangs it's
like everyone in the show is like a
z-list version of uh actual celebrity
it's blowing my mind it that is a very
good point also you know that the show
is produced by Emma Roberts of course we
stand a fellow book I'd love to see her
up there shaking that thing but I guess
you know what you can't be in everything
no especially because the girl who's
playing
um Lily Lucy sure she
um does not look like a college student
and like when she was like breaking up
with her High School boyfriend in that
first scene I'm like you're kidding me
right I thought the same too but then
once she's in college and they have her
dress the way girls would dress in like
2007 in college and her hair is very
uh like simple I want to say
I can believe it more like in the
present scenes eight years forward she
does look like so current with like her
beachy waves and like her vibe but I can
believe all of it and you know I think
it's like so cute do you think girls in
France are doing beachy waves
you know who I think is so cute then and
now
wait let me think Brie yeah
obsessed to the nth degree with braid
like I know she gets a happy ending and
I'm so [ __ ] happy about it she's so
[ __ ] cute when she's dressing
up as sexy vampire I was like oh my God
she's like actually like stunning yeah
um she's such a good friend Pippa is the
[ __ ] vote losorious loser who ever
walked the planet
um and I'm just loving it it kind of
like does make me wish I went to college
like I did go to college but like I went
to NYU I didn't I I took classes like
and I lived at home I feel bad because
it's glamorizing the college experience
even though it's filled with like
torturous like Endeavors as well yeah
and it's really hard to like go away to
a new school and they made it seem so
easy to make friends like it's not
always that easy yeah and then you're
just automatically hanging out with boys
two years older than you like that never
[ __ ] happens no never and like that
guy what what's his name uh who pippa's
dating
Wrigley Wrigley like they're dating day
one like never [ __ ] happen never like
this guy wants to take you to dinner
never happens lol
but I do feel like it's really accurate
um in depicting how [ __ ] mean boys
are to girls in college like they're so
nasty yeah
like I feel like so many people I know
have like literally traumatizing
interactions with boys in college like
they're so [ __ ] rude and like
heartless heartless it's so true like
are you not a human being with feelings
like it's crazy you know and like when
you're in college you just you're on the
precipice of adulthood but like you're
still a child in a lot of ways and I
think we talked about this before how
like a college freshman is so young
compared to a college senior yeah it's
like four extremely formative years and
the fact that like those people are
mingling every single day it's just the
Dynamics are so odd odd and everything
is heightened and you're living in close
quarters and you're all hot and it's
just in the hallways are raging it's bad
it's a recipe for disaster and literally
like wait what's your scene
I think Lily better
um oh because her name is Lily Albright
no her name is Lucy Albright but it's
giving Lily Aldridge that's what I'm
thinking
um I really really liked her then like
as the show goes on in the most recent
episode I'm like oh this [ __ ] is so
wrong and so spoiled and so immature
like she's pissing me off agreed and I
actually don't think that her and
Stephen are OTP at all I don't ship I
don't know he's right for her I don't
think she's right for him the fact that
this goes on for eight years makes me
sad because him and Diana are meant to
be no of course is everything
let me be the one to light a fire inside
those eyes she's totally the one for him
like he can be all that he can with her
when he called her and it's like maybe
potentially gonna open up when he called
Lucy it was like oh my mom she's like
yeah my mom's words too like your mom is
fine like and you know what your mom
[ __ ] your dad's best friend while
your dad was dying is like not that big
of a deal like she was lonely too yeah
and she's so nice to you and she doesn't
even know that you're mad at her and
you're just like writing to her okay
also Max okay
like so max is the guy in the first
scene that she lives with right
yeah
like in the future Oh I thought I had
that thought in the fifth episode they
keep saying Max okay then yeah it is wow
so like she meets two guys eight years
ago and eight years later they're both
still in her life like that's just
unrealistic no and it's just stunted
no and also like Max is [ __ ] creepy
she's literally 17 freshmen and she's
definitely like mature looking but she's
immature acting but like you're gonna
date for eight years like a child you
met when she was in college and like you
and your family were running this bar
that is true it's [ __ ] creepy it is
and he's like oh my God you're so
immature uh no [ __ ] she's a teenager
right right but like she is she is
immature
and but she gives off the vibe that
she's like not like other girls her age
she's so mature and then you actually
like talk to her and she's really
[ __ ] like whiny and immature yeah and
she's not the one for Stephen and
Steven's not the one for her no like
eight years later she like died like
Diana's a woman yeah Lucy's a girl I was
not into Diana but then I was like you
know what
yeah yeah
and like this scene that like really got
to me and like this is what like boys in
college do to girls it's so sad like the
gaslighting like she goes in and she's
like he brought condoms to the city so
like he's literally inviting me out here
but he could be [ __ ] someone after I
leave and the way he spins it like to be
about money I'm like you're so [ __ ]
manipulative like it's literal like
mental illness like being so [ __ ]
manipulative yeah no he's not the worst
a good guy but he obviously has his own
demons no of course oh my God that's
that I feel like they're gonna give us
one episode about break I hope they go
back to college next episode because
it's so [ __ ] depressing his mom is
[ __ ] evil like literally [ __ ] evil
it was reminding me of Jeannette
McCurdy's mom
like abusive but not anything you can
see like she's not physical she's not
even really verbal she's [ __ ]
manipulative yeah like and narcissistic
yes it's literally it was almost carbon
copy of what Jeanette was explaining in
her book oh interesting
so I'm glad you watched and who's that
actress that's not Allison Janny is it
no it's Allison Fanny it's it's Fallas
and Fanning are you glad you watched
oh [ __ ] yeah it's so good and I'm glad I
didn't read the book honestly like right
I'm I'm not feeling like I'm missing
anything
even with luckiest girl alive like I was
so critical because I'm like I know I
feel so personally invested in the book
and I'm like well it should have been
this like it's not an enjoyable way to
like watch a TV show or a movie really
not it's stressful it's stressful
like yeah so I'm glad you were totally
right great
great we'll do the Kardashians recap in
our official TV recap after we get
through the Fast Five is that okay with
you yes let's Jump Right In because
we've got much to discuss in the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you
trying not to get emotional Jackie it's
brought to you by Babel
my fave
if you're like me there's a foreign
language that you regret not learning in
school it's never too late to start with
Babel Babel is the language learning app
that sold more than 10 million
subscriptions thanks to their
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons you can finally cross
learning that new language off your list
so for whatever reason you might want to
be learning a new language just like
brought in your horizons if you're
taking a trip and you kind of want to
know like the basics of the language
that of the country that you're
traveling to Babel is a really great
resource it's super accessible super
easy to get and it's effective like
learning language is low-key like one of
the hardest things to do as an adult
like the fact that we used to do in high
school is so crazy with Babel you only
need 10 minutes to complete a lesson so
you can start having real life
conversations in a new language in as
little as three weeks other language
learning apps use AI for their lesson
plans but Baba lessons were created by
over 150 language experts and voiced by
real native speakers not computers so
you can choose from 14 different
languages with Babel including Spanish
French Italian German all the classics
if you're traveling this uh winter you
know it's so great to go to a country
where you don't even know like the
basics like right left up down you know
check out Babel it's a great thing to do
um in preparation for a trip that you're
planning you can start your new language
learning Journey today with Babel and
right now you can get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to babel.com
TMT that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-.com TMT for up to 55 off
your subscription Babble language for
Life today's episode is also brought to
you by the Clinique Even Better clinical
dark spot interrupter if you have dark
spots it can often feel like a vicious
cycle as soon as one Fades another pops
up we'll break the cycle with the
Clinique Even Better clinical dark spot
interrupter
this powerful serum works on melon and
Rich to fair skin and it helps visibly
correct dark spots such as acne marks
while protecting from future
discoloration
so 94 of people
demonstrated an improvement in Radiance
and visible skin tone including acne
marks in just eight weeks you can see a
39 visible reduction in dark spots in
just 12 weeks so their damage eraser
with the cl302 brightening complex is
now more concentrated with boosted
technology to deliver dramatic
brightening results but it's still
gentle enough for all skin types so if
you have dark spots you know they're
literally like your cross to bear
they're so difficult to get rid of and
once you do successfully get rid of one
what's to stop another one from popping
up I'm coming off the summer which is
when I get a lot of dark spots I've been
like really keeping on my routine with
this serum from Clinique it's oil free
it's non-acnegenic it's fast absorbing
and it is dermatologist developed in
just two and a half hours it'll help
quell redness from irritation that can
trigger new visible spots and worsen
existing spots so get the even better
clinical dark spot interrupter today
it's available at clinique.com you know
that ad just reminded me that last night
Jackie and I posted a new episode up on
our patreon our third episode for the
month of September where we both did our
nighttime skincare routines we get a lot
of skin care requests and we do like one
of every two years because it's always
changing and do you know what I found
out did you watch my part I did I was
[ __ ] cracking up okay so I was using
this like really really I think it was
from
was it from Clinique I think it was oh
okay so I was using this really rich
Clarins
um moisturizer and I was talking in the
Vlog about how like it's literally like
the most rich cream I've ever used like
it actually leaves a white cast on my
face
um and it's like so hydrating and the
consistency it actually is the same
exact consistency as marshmallow fluff
so it's just going on and on about like
this new product they sent me in the
mail for like PR and I was like so
excited somebody leaves a comment ready
and it made total incomplete sense the
whole thing is in French so I wasn't
like uh when I've got it I wasn't like
reading
all the directions but it said Claudia I
hate to break it to you but your
Clarence moisturizer is actually a mask
a de-puffing mask it explains why you're
looking so snatched I use it every
morning to give me my jawline back
I've been using a face mask as
moisturizer I don't know what's with me
like that's the second time something
like that has happened to me everyone
knows the time I put a hair mask on my
face and literally broke out in hives
um I don't know why I'm incapable of
reading things okay but the good news is
it's de-puffing
oh totally and it actually sounds like a
really good concept for a
mask and now I'm going to use it like as
it should be used yeah I think that
you've been I've been influenced totally
so um as you guys know 7.99 every month
will get you access to our patreon
channel five extra episodes a month we
do vlogs and podcasts sometimes we do
podcast Vlogs
um so patreon.com morningtoast 8.799
it's never gone up with inflation even
though it should 7.99 five extra
episodes support your favorite girlies
get great content join the community of
amazing other patreon members join the
Facebook group there's really no reason
not to it's good stuff
it's good stuff okay are you ready for
our first story we'll just jump right in
because the NFL has introduced the Apple
music Super Bowl halftime show the NFL
today announced Apple music as the new
partner for the Super Bowl halftime show
the multi-year partnership brings
together the Super Bowl halftime show
the most watched musical performance of
the year with apple music which
celebrates musicians songwriters
producers and fans and offers the
world's best music listening experience
with a catalog wrong blah blah blah what
okay wrong if they don't offer the best
listening experience I would say Spotify
to 100
um let me say a few things I think that
it's really shocking well it's not
shocking the sponsorship for this
segment is like hundreds of millions of
dollars and I just want to say like this
is really our halftime show because we
are all responsible for Apple being able
to afford this because we've had to buy
new Chargers every six months and new
airpods so first of all Apple you're
welcome second of all um I feel like
when we predicted we we reported a
couple maybe a year ago that the
licensing agreement with Pepsi was up
soon and they probably weren't going to
renegotiate it
um and it costs I think maybe around
like 500 million dollars and we were
saying there are only so many companies
that can afford that and we had guessed
that it was going to be the meta
or maybe even the Uber
yeah we weren't that far off Uber
doesn't have money somehow right they're
like always operating at a loss which is
the most shocking thing yeah they've
been like operating at a loss since
Inception but they're like a billion
dollar company and that's the [ __ ] I
don't understand about like startup
culture Venture Capital culture like how
can you be losing 100 million dollars a
year and be valued at over a billion
dollars you could be losing money every
year when everybody I know spends half
their paycheck on Uber no and it's like
you don't actually have any employees
Uber like you don't even pay your
drivers
it's [ __ ] up it's financially
irresponsible honestly right like get
get on upside you know like use one of
our sponsors like get your [ __ ] together
so do you want to also report the second
story that I had sent you that in this
announcement it seems as though NFL has
dropped a major hint that Taylor Swift
is performing at halftime and it's an
announcement the league made no mention
of a potential halftime performer for
Super Bowl lvii but according to Swift
fans it didn't need to because the
timing of the release said it all the
league curiously dropped the news at
midnight something that's been
associated with swift for years she put
out albums twice since 2020 that were
released at that time okay every single
artist everyone does album is released
at midnight everyone does and she sung
the word midnight hundreds of times in
her tracks
no honestly I don't know who I'm more
embarrassed for TMZ or the swifties
because the swifties are capable of
critical thinking and this is just so oh
it's like well the commissioner was
breathing while he was delivering this
announcement and Taylor Swift breeds
therefore heretofore she but by the way
I think the possibility that she is the
first Apple person is extremely likely
she's worked with apple before she's
been the face of Apple she's really one
of the most famous people in the world
who's never done it so there's a million
reasons why it probably is her but them
using the word midnight is not I don't
think they've decided yet I think this
announcement has nothing to do with who
the first performer is what I'm sure
they have a couple people in mind that
they're talking to I don't think that
the decision has been made
at all so can I can I say something kind
of crazy sure
like I don't want Taylor to perform at
the Super Bowl like because it when you
perform at the Super Bowl you're
performing for all of America you're not
performing for the swifties so we're
gonna get I Knew You Were Trouble 22
Love Story blank space like no thanks
like unless she's gonna sit down and
perform like all too well 10 minute
version and peace from folklore like I'm
not interested honestly like the songs
that people love that like are hits I'm
so I've been done with for years you
know what I mean yeah no I don't need to
hear I made trouble ever again right
um
um like I just I don't is there a world
in which she sits down and does like the
Vault tracks from Fearless no like and
that's what we want is she gonna do
better man no
I feel like we could and she could put
together a set that's a blend of her
hits and the best songs you know like I
don't mind styling blank space I think
those are really still good songs no
matter how much I've heard them I didn't
say style so okay
I just I I can't hear I knew you were
trouble I can hear 22. 22. um
Shake It Off oh my God I can't
I literally can't and like I love Taylor
I would literally lay my life out on the
line for Taylor but like the songs that
really popped off and they were
manufactured to do that like she's a pop
music genius like she knows what's gonna
get like I just can't blank space is
like the best of the worst yeah
and I hope she also gives the real fans
something like you know but that's the
thing the Super Bowl halftime show is
not for the real fans no but good music
is good music yeah she doesn't expect
everyone in America to know every single
song she's about to play so let's play
the good ones
yeah like I literally can't
like like obviously I want her to do it
but like if she doesn't I'll be totally
fine yeah me too I like I like to exist
in Swifty spaces where like we don't
have to sing Love Story do you know what
I mean yeah love story holds I'm fine
with love it it does it does I love you
belong with me it's like top three of uh
favorites you belong with me is a
Timeless track a Timeless track
OG toasters will understand that oh that
song is like literally one of my
favorites it's up there with the climb
like it's favorite songs I completely
agree when we were in Camp you were a
counselor and part of one of the things
we did in Camp is in the middle of the
summer every age division would write
like a song and a cheer so like the song
was like a slow alma mater usually to a
Rascal Flatts song just about how we
live 10 months for two and then the
cheer was like an upbeat like Katy Perry
Vibe and you had the youngest girls on
Camp and you had them sing an original
song to the tune of you belong with me
can I get a verse I think I could get
the chorus okay it was so good like
people were sobbing and it's like the
little girl singing like it's oh no and
they sounded like like Angelic choir
yeah cherubic okay and they're called
the majorettes that's the group yeah
like the youngest girls at Camp it was
like majorettes Debs Tina okay okay and
the canvas called Pocono Trails CPT you
need to know those things yeah where the
major Rats the youngest girls on Camp
but that won't stop
it's actually like a low register for
those young girlies
so
more developed
they were your baritones in the back
also
I just think it's worth mentioning like
Jackie was like kind of famous at camp
this should come as a surprise to nobody
because like you're really good with
words
um she was like no net camp for writing
the best song and Sharon so you would do
a song and cheer in the middle of the
summer with your age group and then at
the end of the summer for color War each
team had a song and a chair like there
are some like I bet if we were going to
go back to our camp now there's not one
single person
who is at Camp who was
at Camp when you and I did Gold Galaxy I
was like voted General my last year as a
camper as a super senior because like
they really always gave it to like the
most charismatic and annoying basically
campers so is me and who was the other
girl who was my Missy sorry Missy she
lost
um good girl though good kid
so wait to write a song in a chair and
obviously I was the General and then
counselors were chosen as like advisors
it was like a Prestige it was like an
honor to be chosen Jackie was of course
selected as my advisor it was nepotism
at its finest
um and Jackie counselor and that stated
I write the best songs so I should be an
advisor by the way I was saying so hard
I wasn't I was in nepotism like I was
the benefactor you were a good camera I
was the most I was the most annoying
camper I was the most annoying camper
like that's what you get when you're the
most annoying camper
so Jackie wrote two of the most
beautiful and like everyone would choose
obvious like you know like I think our
our competitors they chose Year 3000 by
Jonas Brothers like that's so obvious
you know it's hard because you want to
choose a song that everyone already
knows that way they don't you have to
choose you have to teach 300 kids a song
right so they want you to learn a new
tune but
it sometimes there's a great song that
you should teach them it will be better
so Jackie selected for our cheer if I
had you by Adam Lambert which I didn't
even know we all learned it so hard and
okay so we were the gold Galaxy and it
was gold Galaxy versus um blue Atlantis
blue Atlantis so like they were all
about underwater we were all about like
outer space so I'm gonna sing actually
you want to sing
Gold Galaxy uh you do as much as you
know me and I'll fill in if I I
literally know the whole [ __ ] thing
right I don't know the whole thing so we
put our spacesuits on ride through the
Galaxy but all that we can see is a gold
team Victory we can make it to the moon
we can land our ship on Mars gold is
fueled by the power of the Stars
from the Milky Way where we are today to
Andromeda Which is far away we've got
shooting stars we've got planet Mars
we're in good company called Galaxy
who were the team Atlantis thinks
they're gonna beat
Gold Galaxy
the constellations tell us that we will
defeat
Gold Galaxy
we will crush our underwater enemies
Gold Galaxy good Galaxy good galaxy
galaxy
gold Gallop like tell me a [ __ ] you
could write constellation and andromedon
into a [ __ ] original song Nobody
chills mic drop no you want to talk
about chills let's talk about the
original song you wrote for our song
Jackie then selected the most obscure
Lady Antebellum song called We I was
here
nobody had heard of it uh it wasn't
really like the lyrics were so beautiful
but the kids couldn't sing that high so
Jackie like fully had it rearranged like
she composed a new song and it sounds
Vaguely Familiar too I Was Here by Lady
Antebellum but like when I tell you
there wasn't a dry eye in the house no
how does that song go again
um the gold Galaxy but I want to hit the
chorus We Believe
like initials carved in an old oak tree
you wait you didn't see I don't remember
that's like yeah I only I've listened to
lady so many times found together
through this
fight standing here
[Music]
within cause it's our time to win
tonight gold will light up the sky and
come winter time we'll think of the
memories that never died when we look
back on this night and recreate the hype
of poke no Trails we'll tilt up our
heads and reflect the stars in the sky
that
symbolize Galaxy we get a live piano
player Rachel wenner Rachel winner on
the keys
it was so literally stunning and
emotional and obviously we won that
night like how literally how could you
not know like Missy you're a queen but
like me and Seth and Jackie like it was
it was never expected a chance no and
like I know everyone feels that way
about like their color were but when I
tell you like people still talk about it
I'm telling you they still talk about it
no and the way that I feel is like I
don't know the person who wrote those
words like they're so gorgeous they're
so moving like you also couldn't get a
better
uh
theme then Gold Galaxy Galaxy it was
almost unfair
you know yeah well and I just want to
say like I became like really like a
camp like Legend after that and it was
really on your coattails like it was
your songs happy to help
also in the chair we reference your name
so like everyone was saying about
Claudia oh yeah Claude with Claudia and
Seth were bound to be the best it was so
[ __ ] good you guys like I don't know
is it like annoying to hear about other
people's Camp experiences like is that
like hearing about someone else's dreams
I feel like if you didn't go to Camp
it's interesting because it's like what
they're writing original songs these are
kids your teacher eight-year-old
majorettes and they're all singing right
it's so beautiful I feel like if you did
go to Camp you're like no my color War
song and cheer was the best and they're
like wanting to share with us theirs but
we don't want to hear it no we literally
don't care we literally don't care like
at all we also had colorware in um
school which was always really fun
because like you didn't have to go to
class yeah that was really fun so and I
was selected as a general my freshman
year I like have such annoying color War
energy like you know when you meet
someone you're like oh she would have
been selected as a general I can't yeah
but that's why you were selected yeah
it's like Annoying It's supposed to be
well liked but I was not really well
liked in high schools yeah loud you know
outgoing someone who's gonna lead the
troops to Victory
Ah that's us that's us yeah honestly
mentite Teo would have been a color War
General 100 I think old Galaxy share
perform at the Super Bowl
100 we're Adam Lambert with the
remaining members of Queen actually
that's a good idea I would love that he
was incredible at the Jubilee it should
be a tribute to the queen because some
of us are still in mourning the toast
like really has healing powers like when
I sat down here I swear to God I was
gonna go to the hospital after this like
I thought my appendix burst I was in the
worst pain I couldn't even walk here I
had to take a car like oh it's not okay
and now I feel fun it's the power of
gold Galaxy
we started Claudia was like I'm not
feeling well like just so you know and
now we're singing old color War tunes
and that's the power of gold Galaxy it
really is
we will crush our underwear oh so back
to Taylor Swift
um I would obviously support it but like
I'm it's one of those things like if it
doesn't happen I'll like secretly be
happy in my room you know yeah I would
love to see I'm still rooting for
Pitbull I think that he should be he
should have done it when it was in Miami
he's literally Mr 305. that was [ __ ]
rude uh disgusting he has so many hits
he's such a performer I I love him I
always wanted to be Pitbull and maybe
Pink as well a fusion it's the peas
by the way pink by the way pink she'll
be suspended from the stadium doing
acrobatics right like how Lady Gaga like
how Lady Gaga pretended to jump off the
roof of the stadium like pink will do it
right
strawberry
so that's what I want I don't think
that's who we're gonna get but that's
who I want I don't feel like pink is
like a crazy Choice like I think it's
actually she's very like has Mass Appeal
she has so many so many hit songs
probably just as many many as Taylor
Swift
in terms of like Middle America
recognizability yep
uh I think she's a great a great choice
and I still would like Adam Lambert and
the remaining members of Queen I think
we should do like a little
halftime Jubilee
in honor of the Platinum Jubilee
and sigala and Ella Eyre can finish us
out with love
love it's crazy how now that song
reminds me of the queen and it's like
has she ever heard it definitely not
um definitely not yeah
take me back to the Platinum Jubilee 100
times for the days okay our next story
we have to move on are you ready
Ellen DeGeneres is Protege Grayson
Chance is ripping the manipulative
comedian
in a bombshell Rolling Stone interview
published on Thursday the Oklahoma
native Grayson Chance who's now 25
reflected on his life and career after a
viral video of him performing Lady
Gaga's Paparazzi in front of his
schoolmates landed him on Ellen's now
defunct talk show in May 2010 when he
was just 12 years old he said not the
now defunct he said quote we just
couldn't believe what was happening we
were so unsure of what we were getting
into and the person that helped cure all
of that skepticism and chaotic energy
was Ellen when the two first met the
musician claimed Ellen said to him I'm
going to protect you I'm going to be
here for you we're going to do this
together soon after she co-created 1111
a record label that distributed was
distributed by Interscope Geffen a m
records and she signed Grayson as her
First Act she also hooked him up with
high profile managers a booking agent a
Publishers publicist and a brand agent
in October 2010 Grayson released a mini
EP as his touring schedule became more
demanding he claimed that Ellen became
domineering and way too controlling my
whole week my whole month my whole year
could change with one text message from
her that was horrible he added that he
quickly learned that Ellen's opinions
were the only ones that mattered a
source close to Ellen denies Grayson's
recollection of the relationship however
and said the comedian went above and
beyond for the Young musician noting
that sometimes careers just don't take
off
okay the thing is I was like looking at
this because I saw the guy made a tick
tock about it who is he like I don't
know what video they're referencing I
don't remember the video but I remember
him Grayson Chance 12 years old you know
voice of an Angel Ellen I don't remember
where the story ends for me and and it
makes you wonder why I don't remember
literally any of it so I'm feeling like
disconnected from the story but I just
think like if anyone is shocked by this
you shouldn't be like watch her
interview Mason Ramsey and you'll know
that she [ __ ] hates kids yeah but she
makes them her whole personality no she
was the kid girl like the corn kid would
have had his own show on Ellen right now
can you explain the corn kid to me yes
you will love him like I cannot believe
you haven't investigated clips that are
not the original and I'm like who's this
corn loving hero it's like the original
is like a random interview I don't know
if it's with I don't think it's local
news I think it's like a guy with a you
know a YouTube channel he met this kid
was eating corn at like a fair and he
was just saying like I [ __ ] love corn
like what's not to love it's a big a big
lump with knobs it has the juice I can't
imagine a more beautiful thing that's
literally what he said about corn it's
so pure and he's so cute he just [ __ ]
loves corn you know
so then the video went viral and
somebody made like a song out of like
his interview lyrics a big lump with
knobs it has the juice
I can't imagine a more beautiful thing
it's cone a big like it's so cute and he
just obviously everyone ellened him and
he's adorable and so every interview he
does there's like more moments like he's
a star I'm so happy for him that's
gorgeous yeah and honestly I'm glad
Ellen isn't around to ruin it yeah so
regarding Grayson Chance I would love to
hear from Noah Ritter and Mason Ramsey
and you know what their experience was
I think when you get in that position
it's like such a tough spot to be in
because
your life does change like Ellen like
she does you know put you on the show
and hook you up with publicist and he
had an EP and so you feel very indebted
to her which is why she acts like by the
way what kind of [ __ ] freak
billionaire 60 year old woman is like
out here abusing random children and
like manipulating them like get a
[ __ ] life like get a friend your own
age yeah pick on someone your own size
but like the kid thing was like almost
like a little weird like it's not if
they don't feel like they were actually
supported and helped like if you want to
do that and you want to assure kids who
are having viral Fame and show them the
way and actually help them get to where
they're going I think that's that's
sweet that's really amazing but if
you're becoming the kid person you're
actually not helping them they're
finding you to be manipulative
controlling and they're like scared of
you and yeah you control all of the
aspects of their Fame uh yeah that's
twisted
it's [ __ ] weird
yeah
I just like I tried to give Ellen like a
a fair chance and I um
I regret that like she's literally the
worst yeah
and
like she needs to stop like for all I
think she's been stopping this is old
things that happened but it definitely
opens up this can of worms about like
what about the kids like Ellen has
gotten a lot of you know backlash and
media attention for treatment of her
guests and her staff who are adults but
no one like during that time was like
okay so she was this rude to this these
people yet she was like mother hen to so
many up-and-coming children like are the
kids okay
that's actually a really good point like
we never heard about the details of the
children I think she didn't give like a
give a [ __ ] honestly like I don't think
she gave them any of her time okay well
that's better than being like
emotionally manipulative like if you're
of course like using them for her show
like oh that's bad but I hope that was
the worst of it you know yeah if that
was the worst camera and then and then
that's over and it's it right but then
they go get to be on Ellen and Noah
Ritter became the face of like you know
a dog food Purina like he killed it yeah
but where is he now I don't know
I love him I love I would lay my life
out on the line for him any
instantaneously so would I I know you
would are you ready for our next season
he's literally Harry no there he could
be it's right I
it's who knows who Harry will be but
it's very possible or like what he will
look like but he could be like fair
skinned red hair and like you see
another big words out of content 100 100
apparently I know he will be yeah 100
this meals nefarious yet but it probably
is a nefarious meal let's be real never
me never yeah yeah yeah no my kids
cooking skills have really
taken off it might be for you are you
ready for our next story is it the next
story that's brought to you by Land's
End it is
don't just slap your logo on any old
uniform create an extension of your
brand that's ready for anything with
custom apparel from Land's End Business
get fully customized clothes accessories
promotional products featuring your logo
and colors elevated by Decades of
experience and with the Best in Class
customer care let lanzan handle the
inventory while you run your business so
it's quality comfort and style that you
can count on from Land's End since 1993
the year before I was born because I'm
So Young thousands of businesses have
relied on lands and business to fill
outfit their employees they offer
Timeless styles that fit everybody types
with the widest range of sizes that
you'll find in Brandon apparel you can
see your logo in Vivid colors on
t-shirts outerwear hats mugs water
bottles and more they have hundreds of
products perfect for any trade show any
event or any holiday gift see why
thousands of companies count on lands
and business go to
business.landsend.com toast use the
promo code toast for 25 off that's
business.lands end.com slash toast promo
code toast for 25 off
thank you so much our next story is
extremely crazy Diary of a Wimpy Kid and
Riverdale actor Ryan Grantham has been
sentenced to life for killing his mother
yeah I saw this Ryan Grantham was
sentenced to life in prison for the
shooting death of his mother Grantham
who's known for his role in Diary of a
Wimpy Kid and appearance in Riverdale
pled guilty to second-degree murder in
March 2020 for killing his mother
Barbara Waite the 24 year old was handed
a life sentence in British Columbia
Supreme Court in Vancouver on Wednesday
he will not be eligible for parole for
14 years
okay now to be like so insensitive but
like Lord grant them
Lord Grantham would never
Lord Grantham would never oh Robert
oh Robert my friend Abe does the best
Cora Grantham impersonation oh Robert
Albert
it's good I'm sorry back to this kid
this is so [ __ ] wild like who the
[ __ ] kills their mom right and the fact
that he's a cotter now I didn't watch a
Wimpy Kid I don't know if he had a
larger smoke either but this picture of
him from Riverdale that's circulating
like he's so familiar look like looking
oh yeah he played a small role of Rodney
James one of the students in the class
um I think that I'm sorry
that was in a different movie he played
the character in Riverdale who was
responsible for the death of Fred
Andrews he hit spread with his father's
truck when Fred was helping a stranded
woman that was because Luke Perry had
passed away and so they
um killed off his character oh got it
got it
um this is [ __ ] crazy like what and I
just don't understand how it's like life
in prison Parole in 14 years like wow
yeah that's confusing that [ __ ] never
makes sense to me and that is in Canada
so it's not like American law but I feel
like that [ __ ] happens too like life in
prison and then they're out in 15 years
like a life sentence and I think is only
25 years so like don't call it life bro
don't call it life don't call it no
seriously don't call it life bro don't
call life
uh anyways that was really just shocking
news no people people are not okay like
don't go killing your mom okay don't do
it don't you're not gonna be happy with
the results I guarantee it
I guarantee are you ready for our next
story Jeff Garland has revealed his
bipolar disorder diagnosis
the six-year-old actor shared his
diagnosis for the first time in a candid
yet brief Instagram post on Tuesday he
wrote bipolar is a [ __ ]
sometimes it's just too much to deal
with I'm doing the best I can this is
the first time that I've opened up about
this hashtag bipolar the post came only
uh one day not the hashtag
it's Chef Garland on Instagram like no I
know he's literally 65 years old I gotta
um it came one day before the premiere
of season 10 of the Goldbergs in which
it was revealed that his character
spoiler alert had been killed off last
year right star oh wait what they kill
him yeah because remember last year he
shared that although yeah no I know
there were allegations of inappropriate
language on set he was the subject of
some HR investigations and they got rid
of him
no that I remember
um I didn't know that their way of
getting rid of him was just killing him
off
um I guess that makes sense and I hate
to like you know say it sounds like Jeff
Garland is using like Mental Health
um as an excuse and like a PR image
thing but it does feel like Jeff Garland
is using mental health as an excuse for
like a PR thing but you don't think that
he's not bipolar I don't know I just
think like it's very manipulative and
like calculating to
be famous for 60 years and
getting celebrating the Bible and then
tell everyone you're bipolar like right
after you get in trouble before your
final season premieres you know what I
mean yeah I don't know if that's like
[ __ ] up to say like I'm not like yeah
he was diagnosis it reminds me of like
Kevin Spacey when he was getting called
out yeah and he was like I'm gay uh so
we don't care first of all and second of
all leave the gays alone yeah literally
leave the Gaze alone that's so [ __ ]
true no but the thing about Jeff Garland
like his bipolar diagnosis is side I
feel like when we reported on these
stories initially it was like
that's Jeff Garland like yeah no I
didn't think it needed to say they were
describing we're not
concrete enough it was kind of vague it
was like inappropriate language I think
he the way I interpret it is like he's
mean and harsh on tap but like did he
call someone he doesn't play by the rule
these new rules right like did he call
someone a [ __ ] or did he use a slur
like what is it yeah no it was very big
it's very vague and so I feel like uh I
feel I I feel like his career might
aside from losing the Goldbergs like
he's still on curb and I think he's so
well respected I don't think his career
would have changed that much from these
big allegations so I do feel like it's
this bipolar thing is separate yeah I
mean he also was the dad in sleepover so
he really never had to work again no
because when you do a role like that you
can just like live off of the pride
right and when your daughter is Julie
Julie Corky I think that there's really
only one way to go and it's down and
that's what happened to Jeff Carl but
then you wind up on Curbing you're back
up yeah no actually I feel like Jeff
Garland's career could be like a case
study for just like the highs and lows
of Hollywood
it's a lot of highs I think he would
consider a sleepover to be like a
particularly low point in his career
we'll have to get him on the show and
talk to him about it I would love to
know like in his IMDb discography like
how he sees
sleepover when he was making it he was
probably like some you know low budget
thing to do in between projects and he
didn't know it would become like a
staple of a generation I just think
actually sleepover is one of those
movies there are other movies wherever
you do or show or a movie it's like
curse and then there are movies where
it's like everyone him Jane Lynch Evan
Peters Evan Peters
Steve Carell like it was kind of
star-studded and it's like that's where
Stars went and they put what was that
girl's name from aquamarine Sarah Paxton
like she didn't go as far as she should
have I don't care I would lay my life
out on the line for her as well she's a
queen and then we have Luke Corky who's
a Hallmark star the way I would have
given anything as a child to have had
those starfish earrings that she had in
Aquamarine that used to whisper
compliments in her ear
need need also the only one who I guess
didn't get the sprinkle was Yancy but I
feel like Yancey opted out of the spot I
think she took a step back after seeing
like how truly toxic Hollywood was and
she's much better off for it like she
preserved her piece yeah isn't Brie
Larson in the movie too yes no I'm
telling you she's the [ __ ] friend with
the convertible I'm telling you like oh
but also that guy never went anywhere
either Julie Julie Corky like the one
who was in love with her on a great
school bus yeah the love interest okay
that's that's on him though because he
was handsome he had a leading role and
like you didn't he had a cute little
Freckle above his lip like why that's on
him everyone else this movie is where
stars were born
like I'm looking back fondly on the time
I spent with these Mega stars like Steve
Carell Brie Larson Jeff Garland Jane
Lynch and Evan Peters are Mega Stars
Mega yeah they're like really well
respected actors
we need a reunion
like we literally literally these kids
are having a sleepover the grandparents
have to come and watch them
and Julie and her friends go out but
then they accidentally run into the kids
who have gone out also the movie writes
itself
and there has to be a Pergola somewhere
and a little hybrid car
yeah yeah yeah well I guess the like in
this modern version like it would be a
Tesla it would be and I don't want it if
Yancey and speaker boy are not in it and
they got married right they have kids oh
yeah and their kids are eating brownies
not celery
let me ask you a question yeah would you
rather have brownie or a celery
I like how that was a pickup line for
Yancey the movie was low-key like
[ __ ] fat phobic like there's one fat
character and like a guy likes her
because they're talking about brownies
like fat people can talk about other
things sure but in that moment they were
talking about brownies I'm not gonna
have you Slayer this movie I'm not
slandering it but like it was [ __ ]
fat phobic Justice for dancing I don't
think it was
no it's against he wasn't capable of
connecting with another human being over
anything that wasn't food
and it was like nobody
nobody
the guy tiazzy Joanna Brown
I think that
I don't think it was haphobic
I'm just I think oh my God connect over
brownies
yeah but you didn't see Julie quirky and
Sarah Paxton connecting over brownies no
they were with boys it's a coincidence
okay not you covering up the fat phobia
of Hollywood no no not Hollywood
sleepover I will cover yeah I could look
past it yeah so in order like for things
in your life to preserve well and age
well in your mind you have to look past
some of their intricacies you know it's
fine like it's not that deep yeah yeah
that's a little bit about sleepover it's
not that yeah it's one night
it was one night of crazy wild fun one
night we'll never forget
one night are you ready for our fifth
and final story yes Olivia Wilde
fangirls fan girl she fan gargle she fan
gargled over Harry Styles at his final
show at MSG so Olivia Wilde is still
Harry's number one fan I think a lot of
people were dubious about whether or not
they were still together yeah definitely
a lot of people are hoping and praying
thinking that maybe the drama had
changed things or their relationship had
just run its course but it hasn't she
was at MSG cheering him on for his last
show at Madison Square Garden where he
was presented with a banner for
performing 15 consecutive nights at the
iconic venue
I'm happy that like this run is over
because I do think Harry's really tired
but he does still have the policeman he
has like a whole other tour like he is I
think he's going to Australia like he's
not okay yeah he needs a rest and even
in the footage I saw from the show on
Wednesday night which I was about to go
to but didn't he looked so tired yeah no
he's like skinny
and like he's lost weight like he
doesn't look like good and strong he
needs a rest and I feel like every time
a major uh star is going on tour it's
always cut short for either mental
health exhaustion physical health
concerns and it's like why are you guys
acting surprised why did we get to this
place it reminds me of Elvis you're
right you said that Margo said it and
she put it in my brain I'm like oh my
God Harry's literally Elvis literally
and it's like I'll be getting the
cortisone shots and steroid shots in his
ass when will people learn never
Hollywood is literally I'm not like I
don't want to accuse anyone of anything
but I I don't think that a a human being
can do 15 shows like that press Tour all
this without any help
yeah a little whatever it is a B12 shot
whatever they're giving Elvis alcohol
maybe whatever there are things that
help people have energy and that's
problematic yeah and that's not
a recipe for long-term longevity and
he's a mega star and he deserves to have
his rest
cocaine sad Boop choker with a sea view
totally
and some of the stuff is like medical
just Harry definitely does blow like he
has so many songs about cocaine oh maybe
he does it like for fun recreationally
but I don't think he relies on no no no
no but he's definitely a party boy I
don't know him I don't know anything
about him but I don't know me neither to
do 15 shows at Madison Square Garden
like I don't this is hard I don't think
it's cocaine that's propelling him but
there's even no but doctors would give
him just like an Elvis and like they say
it's medicine and it's not no I was just
like looking for a cocaine reference and
I realized there's so many like
um you know that one he literally does
this in a song
so yeah
pretty boy got a party with Harry
I think I can make myself available
I actually just bought some merch from
his website so I'm supporting the tour
for Harry's house because he has one
sweatshirt that says Harry's house so I
had to get it oh my that's adorable he
needs to start making I bet like there's
an Etsy store that sells there's a
Taxi's house always send me baby clothes
people always send me Instagram ads of
like uh fake Harry's house merch I
wanted like the real thing so that it's
something I feel like every time I
bought fake merch like I don't know
what's in the water but it shrinks it
has no color like it never lasts no
here's the thing but when I get the real
deal it's nice
I will never buy fake merch after my
Kanye West Confederate flag Saga do you
remember that that was literally
traumatizing I literally got targeted
for like this remember those Jesus tour
jackets that had like they were like
green bomber jackets they were so sick
and like I couldn't get one so I got
targeted for like this turnt company it
showed up it had a Confederate flag
patch on the arm so I just I literally
never wore it and I left it in my closet
and when I was moving I was showing
everyone my new closet and there was
like a big [ __ ] Confederate flag and
people were like rightfully like what
the [ __ ] and I was like I don't know why
it literally never occurred to me to
like rip off the patch or throw it just
throw I never wore the jacket like just
throw it out you cheap wench
um I got dragged to filth on the
internet you know what that one I did
deserve like what the [ __ ] and it was
right on the heels of like of me being
canceled so people like well maybe she
is like this Confederate girly like
Queen and I was so mad at myself I'm
like you dumb [ __ ] wench like what
are you doing literally when it started
to blow up I remember taking the jacket
picking it up and walking it straight to
my garbage Chute and throwing it down
the Chute I never even wore it like all
that for what for fake [ __ ] merch
that's the lesson don't buy fake merch
fake merch my husband loves buying fake
merch he bought a used tour sweatshirt
for himself before we ever met and now
that sweatshirt doesn't even fit me it
is so tiny and I don't think he bought
it that time the washing from washing
yeah he also remember when Kanye came
out with those shirts of Kim and um
golden Barbie playing tennis so those
are sick he got himself a fake version
of that and why doesn't he get the real
one I don't know like they're hard to
find is he like gaming the system I'm
like being played you're literally
flushing money down the toilet because
after two washes that picture was
indecipherable yeah I mean that real
Jesus is King merch and that's a [ __ ]
quality sweatshirt yeah I will say like
one of the I I I need to start keeping a
list of my greatest regrets
um can you write this down for me okay
wait one second let me start a new list
of Claudia's and I want you to try and
guess
okay give me a clue of like what you're
about to say no no I want you to get to
any of my biggest regrets oh not getting
in the car yeah not getting in the cop
car
um
um I feel like there was one more but
the one that I was just reminded of was
not seeing the life of Pablo concert the
Kanye tour yes I had literally told Ben
I'm like I want to get his tickets he
was like oh like I think it was around
our anniversary he was like let me get
them I'm like okay great next thing I
know it's like a Thursday night I'm
laying in bed and you're at the [ __ ]
concert everyone I know is at MSG I'm
like what the [ __ ] this is what happens
when I let Ben like take care of things
never again I let my husband take care
of things we've never gone on a
honeymoon
oh right so like I said I did get us
those concert tickets because he loves
Kanye and I mean that album at the time
I actually like didn't care for Kanye
right whatsoever now I actually really
like him but I was just being a
supportive girlfriend so like in my
support now I can say I saw that tour
and that's what you did it's when you're
supporting it's one of the greatest
albums I think of all time like it's so
good so I would also buy counterfeit
merch
of yours is not going to see Red Taylor
Swift Red
yeah but I don't really feel like that's
fair because in order to regret
something you have to have had the
option to do it and like I was not a
financially independent I was literally
14. yeah
so that should be one of
um our mom's biggest regrets when you're
a kid like you only get a handful of
concerts that your parents are gonna
right get to go to so like you have to
push for them and like really ask and
show how important it is to you and it
wasn't that important to you it wasn't
that important to your younger self like
I guess because you know we we saw Best
of Both Worlds tour
because that was just leave me alone
okay because
to shut up because that was like a a
person the whole family was obsessed
with it was like an easy sell yeah same
with Glee Yeah well yeah she took us to
see like those like that was like family
things like you know what I mean yeah
we're all obsessed
okay we were all obsessed with Taylor
but I guess not collectively like we all
it was kind of an independent Obsession
right we just used to cry in our rooms
yeah but we all shared rooms so we were
all right crying in our beds
um okay are we ready was that the fifth
and final that was the fifth and Final
so let's dive into the TV recap we're
going to talk about Kardashians new
episode on Hulu that little Southern
Charm recap I'm all caught up which is
brought to you by Honey today's episode
sponsored by Honey the easy way to save
when you're shopping on your iPhone or
computer thanks to Honey manually
searching for a coupon code as a thing
of the past honey is the free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one it finds
to your cart here's how it works imagine
you're shopping at one of your favorite
websites when you're checking out the
honey button will just appear all you do
is Click apply coupons wait a few
seconds and honey will search for
coupons for that website once it finds a
working coupon if it does you'll watch
the price drop I've used it many times
clothing food Electronics makeup
literally I very very rarely I'm
shopping on a website that honey does
not work with
um more often than not they can find a
fabulous promo code for me and I used to
have to search like revolve promo code
like it was so much it was like an extra
job like it was just not like worth it
but honey does all the work for you when
you use our link the browser extension
is totally free to download and now you
can do it on your phone too if you're
shopping online on Safari
doesn't just work on desktop activated
on Safari on your phone you can save on
the go if you don't already have honey
you're straight up missing out by
getting it you're doing yourself a solid
and you're supporting the show we would
never recommend something we don't use
get honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast that's joinhoney.com toast
okay Kardashians they gave us like a
front to back timeline of Chloe's
pregnancy they're not making us wait
till the end of the season so now I feel
like episode two we're actually gonna go
back with the surrogates will be
pregnant ended this one July 28th like
right a month ago literally so that was
nice of them I appreciated that they
dedicated the whole episode to Chloe's
Journey
um I got really choked up
um like multiple times mostly when Kim
was talking like Kim like I felt sad for
Chloe obviously but something about Kim
like everything Kim said was so on point
like her her speech at the really cute I
guess that was their version of a low
budget shower
um was really like she was like you're
not even gonna remember like all this
you're just gonna remember life with
your baby and like nothing before this
even ever mattered and I feel like that
really kind of like spoke to Chloe and
she was like this Baby's gonna show you
what true love is supposed to be
um and I just got I'm literally gonna
cry right now like I got so choked up
um because Kim is not really emotional
but I think like in a lot of ways Kim
was also speaking like on her own
experience I think Chloe's obviously
like pissed at Tristan for betraying her
but I think she's also just like freaked
out to be doing this alone yeah um and I
think like the way you know Kim probably
felt that way too not that Kim's gonna
be a single parent but like when you get
separated like you have alone time like
you're doing a lot of the stuff on your
own so I feel like Kim was just kind of
speaking to her own self too and I was
like really getting emo I was so emo it
was one of the best episodes of any
reality TV that I've ever seen like the
way that it was so emotional and like I
think everybody who watched it like was
crying I Kim's speech also like made me
so teary and even at the the end when
like she's holding a baby tea I was and
she was like it's first kiss I was
literally cracking cracking up oh my God
it was so beautiful and emotional and
what I didn't understand for a while
is like
Chloe and Tristan haven't been together
for a while and so I didn't understand
why Chloe couldn't just be like okay
Tristan's irrelevant but I have what I
want which is like my two kids true has
a brother and like that's what's most
important to me why can't you focus on
that and I didn't real I didn't yeah no
I couldn't understand why she would be
so like
even bothered about what Tristan does at
this point because he's like so
disappointing all the time but what I
didn't realize was how attached she was
to the idea of having a traditional
family unit even if her and Tristan
aren't in a romantic relationship like
in the last few years Tristan has been
like living with them and she could
tolerate him and like true we're seeing
like both of her parents all the time
and like now with this betrayal like she
can't even do that and so it was
important to her to like try yeah and so
really like their what she was saying
about like her kids you know she doesn't
want them to have daddy issues and like
she really wanted them to have that
family unit and it's the idea of that
going away not the romance you know
because that's really hasn't been in
play for a while but the idea that like
she really is a single mom and that
that's what her kids will see I think
that was kind of hard for her to wrap
her head around but I think what she'll
realize is that
she's going to be amazing she no and
kids who are raised by single moms are a
different breed of human being I'm sorry
they are better they are better I'm
sorry that we we are better we are like
single moms are the heroes of the world
and I think you've like learned so much
from your mom
um when your mom's saying oh Mom you're
just like in awe of like her strength
and her like I'm sorry it's actually
gonna end up being a good thing not that
Tristan's dead but like he's [ __ ]
irrelevant yeah now I also think there
are two other things so why maybe my
perspective this whole time was like
okay so you can do it like right because
you're amazing because we are the
benefactors of a single mom so it's like
yeah [ __ ] rocks like yeah no that is
it's not that bad it's not that like
of a big deal and and that yeah you know
it doesn't but anyways I think she not
only had like her dad that she looked up
to she also had uh Caitlyn Caitlyn
father figure for so many years like she
had two and now no it's true have this
one uh yeah well so I also think there
were two other things I think part of
the reason she like couldn't get out of
the rut was because she herself wasn't
pregnant so like it it definitely feels
like a more of a disconnect like if
you're pregnant and you're going through
something hard you focus on like the
belly and the kicks and like you feel
the baby with you every step of the way
not having that has to have made it a
little bit more difficult to focus on
the fact that like a baby's coming into
the world dad but I think actually what
was the hardest part is that she no one
could know she didn't want anyone to
know yet because then if it got out she
had to deal with everybody's opinions so
it's like even if she wanted to be
excited she can't talk about it in her
own house she can't have a shower she
can't get back and ready because she
can't have anyone by the way because she
doesn't want the the top secret because
of what Tristan did and the way she said
that she can't have furniture delivered
to her house yeah or even the fact that
like when she told true then like true
might let it slip to someone and so her
and true can't even just sit around and
like talk about how excited they are I
think that that really was the biggest
hindrance because she was so worried
about people finding out and I and now
I'm thinking she was like dumb yeah
whenever it came out whenever it was
going to be she was gonna have to deal
with it and so I think that secrecy was
all it's so like making her sick because
she knew that was waiting for her at the
end and I hope that when everything did
come out
that she was okay I don't yes I think
she was healed I don't know if things
leaked because
I like how did it come out when it did
why the baby wasn't here yet did they
decide no but she got enough time yeah
she had she had a lot of time but I just
oh my gosh it was so emotional no and
you know one thing I didn't really think
of that like really made me [ __ ] hate
Tristan like really kind of it it
brought his betrayal to another level
when like they were showing footage of
like he was the one really pushing to
like get the embryo transfer done and
because like as sooner or later he was
not going to be able to avoid Chloe
finding out about Theo
um and so like
her thinking that like he's excited to
have a baby and he's just pushing it so
that she'll get pregnant before
Theo is like out in the world it's it's
literally so disgusting now another
factor that I didn't just like I didn't
expect like a scene that like started my
my tears Kim really brought them to
fruition but I got like teared was Cece
it was just such a fresh totally
um honest reaction to Good News you know
obviously she knows about Tristan and
everything but like just someone who was
really isn't like that involved finding
out and just being happy for Chloe I was
like yeah like that's what it's supposed
to be like like I thought Cece's
reaction was fabulous and I think it
helped Chloe turn a corner
and at in the beginning I was like Chloe
doesn't want a baby shower like don't do
it like but I think that yeah and I was
like why is Chris pushing that it was
exactly what she needed like to
experience some of the joys because it's
always so joyful obviously the the storm
cloud completely eclipsed that but
overall it's like the most beautiful
thing and Chloe was having a hard time
seeing it through the storm
where was Courtney she was in Kendall
I don't know but Kylie was picking up
the slack I love as it's time I love my
postpartum Queen so it's time I need it
it's time Kylie she's just the best you
know this this episode being Chloe Kim
Chris Kylee like I'm good with the four
it's enough for me Diana sprinkle of
CeCe didn't even notice Scott wasn't in
it yeah it was one of honestly the
episode deserves an Emmy like it was it
was beautiful unreal and I'm happy and
the fact that like Kim was the one in
the room with her like made me so emo
yeah and I'm happy for Chloe I think the
reception to this episode is going to be
really good like hopefully she can if
she you know continue to turn a new leaf
and realize that like P we love you
Chloe we love you so much and like the
people who like make those memes and say
the old one boring [ __ ] like don't don't
know what real life is like and yeah you
are so loved by not just your family but
really by everyone
I was really shocked to hear that like
you know people and like their chatter
on the internet like factors in you know
is is something that she thinks about
and honestly
um it made me feel really good because
that's like oh we are all human
even like the most famous rich like
it gets to everyone at some point you go
through highs and you go through lows
yeah
I just I I was such a good episode
because at the end of the day the
takeaway was no matter what happens in
life like family is everything and
family is here for you and like I was
literally getting so choked up like and
at the end of the day Tristan did even
though he's literally the worst he did
her favor by having her them get
pregnant before Chloe could because she
wouldn't have done it she wouldn't have
done it and I think this baby is such a
blessing and true has a brother snowy
people think that that was a clue for
Kylie's baby's name because she was like
it's snowy because stormy's little
brother's name would be snowy
totally but I don't think I think they
probably call
baby boy Webster snowy as like a
nickname because of like stormy and
snowy especially when he didn't have a
name that's my theory
oh I didn't even think of Stormy and
snowy okay wait the child's name is
definitely snowing or snow
I love the name snow I know you do
so Kylie you have my sealable by the way
I love that love
love that's totally it
um okay now tell me about southern charm
I'm like I'm I'm over it like honestly
Southern Charm is so [ __ ] good last
night's episode was not because everyone
was too drunk to function and the fights
were like fake and manufactured a few
interesting things happen but actually
Leva they went to Saint Simon on a trip
and love actually didn't go because she
was like I'm so tired of at dinner the
boys will all be fighting because this
is a show about boys fighting and then
the next day they're all golfing and
they're fine and like we're all left to
like pick up the people picking up our
dinner was just ruined we all think
we're in disarray but the boys are fine
and like we're just here having had a
terrible night that's actually such a
good point so she didn't go and that's
literally what happened the first night
everyone's drunk Austin and chap are
screaming at each other so crazy because
Austin is I mean Chef is like so
controlling with Taylor like really just
not a great boyfriend and then the next
day
Shep and Whitney and Naomi are golfing
are fine and
then everyone else goes shrimping what
was so interesting though was like so
Vanita came onto the show and she's
really like a girl's girl she's friends
with the girls she has long-standing
friendships with um Madison Naomi and
leather and I think the way that the
need uh saw the boys is like oh these
like immature boys who are always
causing drama whatever and she never
really saw like the reason why so many
people love them and then like how
they're really so Charming anyway so
that day they all uh Shep Naomi and
Whitney went and played golf and Vanita
Olivia Taylor
Craig and Austin went shrimping and I
think it was the first time Vanita saw
that like Austin and Craig are Austin
and Craig and they're so affable and
there's a reason why like you know
everyone's like falling in love with
them and they're really I think so
Charming as people they put the charm in
Southern Charms they really do and even
when they come to the studio we're just
like oh my God awesome we're like shook
like they're so tall and so cute and
like honestly like they've got Pizzazz
they've got Pizzazz and I think she even
said in her interview she was like I
never saw this side of Craig before
because she's only been friends with
Naomi who knows so she knows right him
as that part anyways that night at
dinner they're at the table Naomi and
Craig are arguing and Bonita says
something like Naomi's just like listen
to how he feels and they're Naomi and
benite are friends of 10 years and then
all of a sudden it's taking Craig's side
because Bonita is Swept Away by Greg's
charge she's been swept away and she
wasn't like taking his side but like she
was just being like listen to how he
feels which is right something that a
moderator says and Naomi was like Anita
shut up
no sorry I'm with Naomi on that like
seriously like you're my friend of
course like I'm fighting with my ex and
you're gonna literally be like not like
other girls pick me energy like one day
of shrimping yeah relax Vanita right so
it was honestly I don't know how they're
gonna it doesn't look like next week
they come back from it either I don't
know what's gonna happen it was just
like this one moment and it's just the
charm of Craig and Austin no and I think
like people when they go online and
discuss Southern tribe like I can't
believe like everyone's like simping
over awesome like they love to like rag
on the boys
um and I get it but like if you meet
them first of all they're all so
handsome like I was really shocked like
Austin is like
extremely good looking I mean he's so
tall and so funny and very out there and
like there's a reason why people are
drawn to them I think even Shep too like
eat those yeah like they're they just
have this way about them so it's funny
to see it like happen on the show and it
caused like drama within the girls
whereas the girls are always the
non-dramatic party next week is the
season finale Craig is having a party at
sewing down south Paige will be there
even though she like does not like
filming the show which is sad for the
rest she went to the reunion though did
you see they last night I think it was
The Reunion she wore this orange get up
she's like oh I saw that they were
filming something and I saw that her I
think that was it they were holding let
me double check they were holding like a
no I I looked really close at the Slate
thing and I think it was something for
bravocon because it said something about
like a vacation
zoom in I don't think it was a reunion
um
it says shooter McGee ticket to Paradise
yeah it's like a commercial thing no it
looks like one of those sponsored
commercials for a movie called ticket to
Paradise great
I'm obsessed obsessed this season has
been a lot of Craig and Naomi beefing
it's just so weird because like who
cares no no just Craig and Naomi should
never really see each other again they
were it's not like they were really good
friends but maybe they were friends
before they started dating but we never
knew them as friends their relationship
like they were living together they were
so serious like serious so emotional it
took years like years for Craig to get
over it like he shouldn't be having
dinner with Naomi and everything no it
sucks triggers him because he thinks
it's like because it just brings him
back like she said to the whole table no
you guys need to be like kinder to the
wait staff and like when they come over
you need to like stop what you're doing
and pay attention wow good for her and
Craig was like you worked in food and
bed for how many years because he felt
like not the food like because he yeah
no but you're right a person like Naomi
to Craig or a person like Craig to Naomi
those are the type of people once you
break up after like being in love like
your first love you never see them again
there's no friendship after that so I
don't think anyone is still hung up on
the other person I think that is so
[ __ ] triggered by each other and it
makes it seem like neither of them are
over the other but I really think that
they are I also have to say 100 fully
ship Naomi and Whitney I thought that
they're like one night uh that they just
like kissed One Night in the season but
like they're like being a little couple
here and there and I think they're so
cute together
and I hope they get married
oh my God I hope they get mad and I hope
that Patricia is Naomi's mother-in-law
she's gonna officiate it and that they
like move into the house one day I think
that because Naomi's so sophisticated
and Whitney is like very you know yeah
she's like a French girl she's a French
girl so like they go to restaurants they
order in French he's such a snob but
she's up to the task and I think they're
actually really cute couple no I
actually see that yeah
um okay well I'm so glad I'm not
watching but I'm literally feel like I
am you know yeah no it's so good I love
the crew also uh Olivia and Austin are
like being coupling and cute now I think
they're still together I hope that they
are oh okay I don't love that for her
why
because like I love Austin but like
my only concern about Austin is every
season of Every show that he's on he
always is white he has a girl yeah and
you think like remember Chelsea he was
like so right over here like is nobody
special right and then it was Madison
and now it's Olivia and he's like all in
but Sierra why Sierra why like he goes
to Winter house for two weeks he has a
girlfriend Sierra why don't these
relationships work for him yeah no it's
definitely a red flag but
maybe this for now it's fine and maybe
now with like Craig Craig keeps talking
about how he's gonna marry page and if
he doesn't marry her like that he will
be heartbroken like that
100 so maybe that maybe for some guys
it's just about timing I like really
need to work on becoming better friends
with Paige like I need to be at the
wedding I'm like I'll cry I need to
officiate it I need to sing them down
the aisle like I want to be involved in
their love story get involved
get involved actually I did speak to
Taylor's trucker last night
um
I'm gonna try and set up a dinner
love it yeah
because like you don't understand like
the obsession like it's actually [ __ ]
it's actually weird you know what it's
everybody has them
you know totally who's yours oh I have I
have so many but like it's crazy how
sometimes they like cycle in and out of
my life but some of my long-standing
ones like Olivia Culpo mm-hmm open the
door also we never talked about that her
and her sisters are getting a reality
show on Discovery plus called the copos
it's like done and premiering soon
cool no I'm really like no I love her
would lay my life out on the line for
her
um I just feel like
they should have done it not not that
it's on them but like the industry
should have done it three years ago I
think that's when they started doing it
plus kovid but I think her and her
sisters have a really great Dynamic
sisterly love I mean they're so stunning
they're so stunning it ain't right how
stunning they are yeah
no I mean I'll definitely watch like I
think that like we I would actually find
it like um really interesting and I
think I would find that like we have a
lot in common with them yeah so a
discovery plus I think I already
subscribed because I don't um they have
some good subsidiaries I think like
lifetime is part of Discovery yes I was
like Food Network yeah HGTV Magnolia
Network oh I've watched all the episodes
of Magnolia yeah I gotta do that
Bruno's a lady love
so that is our show I just want to
remind everyone that Monday and Tuesday
of next week is Rosh Hashanah so Jackie
and I will not be doing episodes but
we'll be back on Wednesday so try and
make it without us at the beginning of
next week just know that we are you know
being God's girlies and that's very time
consuming and we're ushering in the New
Year the Jewish New Year so to everyone
who celebrates happy Rosh Hashanah
shanato
um hope you enjoy the holiday with your
family or your friends and your food
um to our non-jewish non-celebrating
toasters enjoy a day at work you should
really convert we get so many days off
love ya thank you so much for listening
to the morning testimony Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know everybody through
Friday on YouTube so you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast into
our podcast and we found so at Spotify
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are bye bye